the population over the last 50 years
has gone from 3 to 8 billion and the
next 50 years it's expected to go from 8
to 12 billion most of that growth is
going to be in the African continent
that's going to show we're gonna have a
real boom in Africa because there's
gonna be a much younger population there
and that's going to be great we're good
one median age of about 18 right yeah
stands and really booming and Nigeria
will be the biggest of all of those and
so and and I think that that world will
rise and so we're gonna start in some of
the other lesser developed countries are
also going to rise around the globe and
I think we're we're not going to feel so
different going across borders and Isis
so I think that's gonna be really
interesting you you mentioned a new
technology that that can do all this
great stuff like you can you can
replicate meat without killing an animal
and you can but you can also use it for
bio air warfare that's always been our
choice whenever there's a new technology
that technology first tends to win all
the wars but it also tends to move
society forward in a magic and
imaginative ways and I think that's
always going to be the case there will
always be the the the group that says
hey how can I use this for power and
then how can I use this to improve
humanity that would be the other group
and the ones I think that are that are
clinging to power right now are I think
are sort of a dying breed I actually
think that humanity is winning out and
it's it has to do with social media with
all the communications vehicles we have
now I kind of had the sense that when we
had free communication around the world
when we did hotmail and I came up with
the viral marketing idea well
was going to really open the world up
and it really has so that we're all very
very interconnected and interrelated
through just friendships but also
through businesses and through walks of
life different ways of operating and so
that's when when you see one country
threatening another you think wait a
second that's just that guy that leader
so-called leader being mad at that other
leader because down on the at the at the
human level we already have great
friends in those countries I mean I
think of all this friction between the
US and China
that's friction between the two leaders
of those countries it's not friction
between us we have we have amazing
relationships with all those people in
China I've been working in China for 50
years 30 40 years now
and and had built some amazing
relationships and now I look at any kind
of a war or whatever that kind of the
the danger zone as the equivalent of
just you know shooting off your own leg
in order to you know see if you can
hobble a little faster with your
remaining leg it it really doesn't make
sense except to those leaders who are
trying to cling to power that's that's
going to be the threat that's going to
be we are moving to a new level
society is moving to a new way of
thinking the leaders have to catch up
and it's interesting the leaders of
these smaller countries are going yeah
how do I do this how do I use Bitcoin
what do I do with you know how do I get
more venture capital here how do I get
more citizens to come to my my country
and there and they're also saying things
like wait how did Estonia do the virtual
citizenship thing how do I do that how
Malaysia already has a virtual residency
and Kazakhstan's working on a virtual
citizenship program so there are lots of
countries that are all kind of going huh
this is interesting